he may be done fighting the White
Walkers but Kit Harington isn't putting
a sword down anytime soon while on stage
at the 2019 d23 Expo on Saturday August
24th Marvel Studios had Kevin Feige
revealed that Game of Thrones alum Kit
Harington will be joining the MCU here's
who he's playing and just what you'll
need to know about him
Kit Harington will be playing Dane
Wittman much better known to comic book
readers as Marvel's Black Knight in the
upcoming Marvel Cinematic Universe film
Eternals joining his one-time on-screen
brother Richard Madden who was also cast
in the film longtime fans of both Marvel
and the Avengers will be excited to see
the Black Knights inclusion into Marvel
Studios massive money-making universe
the characters big screen debut is
finally arriving after years of rumors
that the sword wielding superhero would
make the leap from the comic books to
the MCU Dayne Whitman is actually the
third character to wear the mantle of
the Black Knight and he first appeared
in the Avengers number 47 way back in
December 1967 Harrington's character is
a descendant of the original Black
Knight and is the nephew of the
villainous second Black Knight who
perished after a fight with Iron Man
after his evil uncle died Whitman
inherited the ebony blade cursed
mystical sword that has been passed down
from generation to generation and took
the black knight identity to help
restore honor to his family name the
Black Knight has been a longtime member
of many different incarnations of the
Avengers lineup throughout the history
of Marvel Comics he's also joined up
with other popular teams like the
defenders and Heroes for Hire while the
Black Knight has generally been featured
in team-up books he's also had a few
chances to take the spotlight for
himself and shine in some solo
adventures the character and his legacy
was the focus of a four-issue miniseries
in 1990 with a couple of one-shot issues
coming out over the years following that
first solo outing the Black Knight even
had a real chance to take the comic
world by storm in 2015 when Marvel
decided to take on a full line wide soft
reboot known as all-new all-different
marvel the ongoing Black Knight series
that spun out of the
event was the first ongoing series to
feature Dane Whitman as a comic books
lead character
unfortunately the series was cancelled
after only five issues still Whitman's
Black Knight is sure to become more of a
household name in light of his inclusion
in the MCU and that could mean big
things for the character in the comics
as well the announcement is huge news
for harrington himself as many have
wondered what the actor's career would
look like in the face of Game of Thrones
finally coming to an end after years of
pop culture dominance the 32 year old
actor has yet to find much success
outside of Westeros with the most
notable non Game of Thrones moments in
his filmography being the 2014
historical disaster film Pompeii and
motion capture work in the 2016
installment of the Call of Duty video
game franchise if Harrington is going to
parlay his Game of Thrones exposure into
a full-fledged lengthy Hollywood career
he'll have to help Marvel can continue
its streak of turning actors into
household names the likes of Chris Evans
Tom Holland and Chris Hemsworth have the
MCU to thank for their current ælis
status and with a dragon sized hole in a
schedule Harrington has to be chomping
at the bit to be playing another
character with franchise potential it's
unclear how Dane Wittman will fit into
the Eternals as of yet in the comics
Dane becomes romantically entangled with
Cersei who will be played in the
upcoming film by Jemma Chan still Feige
and company are no strangers to changing
up the lore and events of the source
material to fit their needs on the big
screen getting an actor as popular as
Kit Harington for such a surprising role
could mean the character has a big role
to play in the MCU going forward the
Eternals will arrive in theaters on
November 6 2020 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]